my next guest got a firsthand look at
the situation yesterday when he traveled
to the border alongside of the lawmakers
florida republican congressman and
homeland security committee member
carlos jimenez joins me now congressman
tell us what you saw look i saw what i
saw
really broke my heart i saw hundreds of
kids in a
customs and border patrol facility well
treated but hundreds of them
that had come across the border
unaccompanied
they're being trafficked uh by
multinational cartels that really
hold all the key to getting through
mexico they're being charged
i don't know how many thousands of
dollars per child and they're here by
themselves and so
you know this is just a byproduct of of
the rhetoric of the biden administration
and their policies they're switching the
policies of the trump administration
and it's telling migrants hey come on
come on in tell them hey send your kids
come on in
and that's the message that's been sent
and they're taking you know they're
taking it to heart and they're coming in
in droves and uh it's really
heartbreaking to see those kids
many of them probably were abused uh on
their trip
uh we don't know where they're headed uh
who who
who it is that they're supposed to you
know take care of them some of them have
uh stickers on them telling hey call
this number that may be
you know an aunt or an uncle but at the
end we won't know and we don't have
enough people to follow up with it so
it's pretty tragic situation down at the
border
yeah i read this morning 4 200 children
in cbp
cells and in one sector in the rio
grande valley
was at 363 percent of capacity
this is i mean this is a crisis i know
fema was called up i know
the biden administration is trying to
you know cover it up cover up the public
relations aspect of it
but should there be a greater sense of
urgency considering just
uh the humanitarian problem here
yeah the humanitarian problem is
actually caused by the policies because
look you've got migrants that are taking
their life
and putting it at risk their and their
children's they've got to pay these uh
these smugglers
these traffickers thousands of dollars
you know customers of border patrol
they they estimated that those smugglers
that those uh cartels
made at least 400 million dollars last
month alone
uh smuggling you know uh migrants into
into this country and so it is a
humanitarian problem
we need to disincentivize this surge we
need to tell people hey
you know don't come to the united states
we're going to abide by our laws i think
one of the things we need to do ada
had a heck of a lot more judges so that
a lot of these
asylum cases can be done quickly uh have
them stay in
in mexico not you know we we had an
agreement with them they would stay in
mexico
that was broken we had agreements with
the central american countries
that was broken all that incentivized
all this this
surge that we have we're seeing right
now and by the way it's only going to
get worse
this is just the beginning of this tidal
wave that's going to come our way
representative jimenez thank you very
much